the kovit 19 pandemic has shaken the
whole world
and has sent us clear messages it has
shown us the strength of global
cooperation
and that no one is safe until everyone
is safe
with the wh show we built the global
framework to accelerate the development
of covid19 vaccines
treatments and tests the act accelerator
the eu has invested 4 billion euros in
research and in the production capacity
of vaccines
now being delivered not just to the eu
but to countries
all over the world the covet 19 pandemic
represents a shock of historic
proportions for
our economies here in europe but we are
not forgetting those hit hardest
the eu through the g20 has been
supporting
efforts to provide developing countries
additional physical space and depth
relief
so that they can spend on health and
social protection
including to buy vaccines
the world cannot afford that the kovit
19 crisis
also turns into a debt crisis for many
developing countries
and we have not forgotten the most
vulnerable in hard-to-reach
or conflict-affected areas where
covet-19
further aggravated their already dire
situation
the eu's humanitarian airbridge has been
instrumental
to bring over 1150 tons
of vital medical supplies to the most
fragile communities in 20 countries
all over the world the eu civil
protection mechanism
has also been key to facilitate
logistical support
of vital medical supplies donated by our
member states
most recently oxygen cylinders and
ventilators to
india but also vaccines to our partners
we will further support with 100 million
euro
the rollout of vaccination campaigns in
several african countries
with fragile health systems and
humanitarian settings
we are determined to fight the virus
beyond eu borders
team europe has mobilized over 40
million euros to
help our partners address the pandemic
but people need vaccines now
half of the 400 million doses produced
in the eu
has been shipped to our partners
through an almost 2.5 billion euros
investment in kovacs team europe is
leading efforts
to share vaccines around the world
more doses will follow with the eu
vaccine sharing mechanism
but our commitment goes beyond emergency
measures
we must make sure this is the last
pandemic
we face we are working
hard to help partners better prepare
for the future global health threats to
prevent crises
with investment in health systems
strengthening
team europe is also developing an
initiative
with african partners to boost
pharmaceutical capacity
in africa because in the end there is
only one race the one against
the virus and we will only stop it
together
you